le peuple américain vient de se
prononcer il avait lu donald trump
président des états unis je le félicite
comme il est naturel entre deux chefs
d'états démocratiques
j'ai une pensée pour hillary clinton
avec laquelle j'ai eu à travailler
durant la présidence obama
cette élection américaine ou une période
d'incertitude je doit l'aborder avec
lucidité et clarté les états unis
constitue un partenaire de tout premier
plan pour la france et ce qui est en jeu
c'est la paix c'est la lutte contre le
terrorisme c'est la situation au
moyen-orient sont les relations
économiques caisse et la préservation de
la planète
sur tous ces sujets j'engagerai sans
tarder une discussion avec la nouvelle
administration américaine
elle entrera en fonction le 20 janvier
mais je le ferai avec vigilance et
franchise car certaines positions prises
par donald trump durant la campagne
américaine doivent être confrontés aux
valeurs et aux intérêts que nous
partageons avec les états unis et
l'amitié entre nos deux peuples et notre
histoire commune
nous y aider la france poursuivra
également la coopération transatlantique
sans concession et en toute indépendance
ce nouveau contexte provoquées par
l'élection américaine exige plus que
jamais que la france soit forte et
qu'elle prenne ses responsabilités
partout dans le monde
comme je lé fais depuis 2012 ce contexte
appelle également à une europe unie est
également capable de s'exprimer et de
porter une politique partout où ses
intérêts ou ces valeurs sont en cause
je pense à la liberté à la dignité à la
cohésion sociale et contre la pauvreté
enfin des leçons sont forcément tirer de
tout scrutin une élection américaine va
bien au delà des seuls états unis et
cette élection vient après d'autres
scrutins
nous devons regarder en face cette
situation
et là encore prendre conscience des
inquiétudes qui sont provoquées par les
désordres du monde dans tous les peuples
y compris le peuple américain première
puissance du monde alors nous devons
trouver des réponses
elles sont en nous et elles doivent
justement être capable de dépasser les
peurs mais aussi de respecter les
principes qui nous fonde la démocratie
et le modèle social plus que jamais
cette élection nous conduit à prendre
les responsabilités qui doivent être les
nôtres celles de la france et l'europe
étant l'instrument le cadre même de ce
que nous avons à faire la france
d'abord la france en toute indépendance
et l'europe avec m merci